all right cut it out
that's enough horsing around just just
knock it off yes you as well
these kind of pissed off working
arthropods are globular spring tails and
they aren't actually fighting they're
getting it on but before we get to that
there are lots of kinds of spring tails
they're called spring tails because
they've got an appendage kind of like a
tail that they used to fire themselves
out of danger check this out here in the
circle need upper right I'm not sure why
that's so funny anyway the globular
spring tails when a boy globular spring
tail and a girl globular spring tail
love each other very much they kiss for
a long time the bigger one here is in
fact the female the tiny male uses his
specially shaped antennae to hook on to
his giant ladies face thus begins
they're less than graceful first dance
by waving him around the female is
pretty much saying I'll take some sperm
please he'll deposit that sperm on the
ground as a tower called a spermatophore
then guide her on top of it then shall
take up the spermatophore into her
genital aperture as it's known so yeah
he's essentially a sperm gun she wields
with her face and there you have it
making babies the old-fashioned way
where the sperm gun maybe that isn't
very old-fashioned